hello that I reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey we're gonna watch the
egg a short story presumably short film
this comes from a YouTube channel who's
killing it on the interwebs right now
Kurt Kurt Kurt Kurt he's got sucked in a
nutshell that's how you say it
there's a top reward to your video
request from our patreon top patron Pete
dawn he said that this really ain't
found inspiring actually I'm very moving
so I figured yeah let's check this out
you were on your way home when you don't
it was a car accident nothing
particularly remarkable but fatal
nonetheless it was a painless death the
medics tried their best to save you but
to no avail
your body was so utterly shattered you
were better off trust me and that's when
you met me what happened where am I hmm
you died I said matter-of-factly no
point in missing was there was there was
the truck and it was speeding
yes I I died
yes but don't feel bad about it everyone
dies you looked around there was nothing
this just see that from me what is this
place
is this the afterlife more or less they
you god yes
I'm God my kids my wife
what about them will they be all right
that's what I like to see and I said you
just died and your main concern is for
your family that's good stuff right
there you looked at me with fascination
to you I didn't look like God I just
look like some man or possibly a woman
some legal authority figure maybe don't
worry I said they'll be fine your kids
will remember you as perfect in every
way they didn't have time to grow
contemptuous of you
your wife will cry on the outside but
will be secretly relieved to be fair
your marriage was falling apart honor if
it's any consolation she'll feel very
guilty for feeling relieved Oh neither
you'll be reincarnated okay okay so the
Hindus were right all religions are
right in their
way walk with me you followed along as
we strode through the void where are we
going nowhere in particular
part of our plan that we talk so when I
get reborn I'll just be a blank slate
right the baby so all my experiences and
everything everything I did in this life
no matter not so you have within you all
the knowledge and experiences of all the
old pals lives
you just don't remember them right now I
stopped walking see a little spirit that
was her dead
your soul is warm is innocent beautiful
and gigantic then you know possibly
imagine
a human mind can only contain a tiny
fraction what you are it's like sticking
your finger in a glass of water to see
if it's hot or cold you put a tiny part
of yourself into the vessel and when you
bring it back out you've gained all the
experiences it had you had in a human
for the last 48 years
so you haven't stretched out yet so it
felt to the rest of your immense
consciousness if we hang out here for
long enough you'd start remembering
everything but there's no point to doing
that between each life how many times
have I been reincarnated then well not
lots and lots and a lot of different
lives this time around you'll be a
Chinese peasant girl in 540 ad upgrade
wait what you're sending me back in time
well I guess technically timers you know
it only exists in omnipresent a flat
circle from where where you come from
oh I come from somewhere somewhere else
and there are others like me I know
you'll want to know what it's like there
but honestly you wouldn't understand
that oh you said a little let down but
wait if I get reincarnated to other
places in time I could have interacted
with myself at some point sure happens
all the time
and with both lives are only aware of
their own lifespan you don't even know
it's happening
so what's the point of it all I looked
you in the eye
the meaning of life the reason I made
this whole universe is for you to mature
you mean mankind you want to ask to
mature no just you
I made this whole universe for you with
each new life you grow and mature and
become a larger and greater Internet
Explorer to assist Jesus me just me what
about everyone else there is no one else
in this universe there's just you and me
we all live within our own University
but all the people on earth all you
different incarnations of you we are one
with Jean I'm everyone we are one with
darkness ways of us I'm every human
being who ever lived
or who will ever live yes I'm Abraham
Lincoln and you're John Wilkes Booth -
I'm a Hitler you said the cold and
you're the millions he killed I'm Jesus
and you're everyone that's Greg out
every time you victimize someone you
were victimizing yourself and an act of
kindness you've done you've done to
yourself every happiness sad moment ever
experienced by any human was or will be
experienced by you you thought for a
long time why why do all this because
someday you will become like me because
that's what you are you're one of my
kind you're my child Wow you said
incredulous you mean I'm a god no no yes
you're a fetus you're still growing
once you've lived every human life
throughout all time you will have grown
enough to be born songs that contain
universe it's just or if the Sun burns
Hank
I answered now it's time for you to move
on to your next life and I said to you
on your way
that's gonna be disconcerting
right
[Music]
well support us yeah supports me support
to you because we are all one by
supporting one of us you're supporting
yourself and all of us so if you
actually pledge to our patreon page
you're pledging to every patreon page it
works that way kill all the birds with
one stone because that's the only pledge
it's gonna happen out of any of this and
you might get your video up on YouTube
that's great
yeah that's beautiful a lot yeah I love
the unique avatar kind of I mean avatars
and the James Cameron movie just you
never heard I was played by Sam
Worthington yet definitely just the the
avatar kind of drawings you always have
her here this seems to deal a lot with
the existential kind of beliefs that I
have developed over the years one book I
read a long time ago twice was called
conversations with God and for the most
part a lot of what is taught in there
seems in summation with this so I
thought it was cool to kind of see a
short story format version of it but I
have an odd theory too
this was inspired by the movie 50 first
dates okay yeah definitely I can see
that there's a lot of jokes about Adam
Sandler makes fun of it in all his
movies but it's especially like
quadrupled down in 50 first dates of he
has an egg head and then she draws a
picture of an egg egg and then every
single day she wakes up she has to get a
new explanation RiRi explained this and
embark on a new life but then it's
restarting every single day and similar
for this character
every time he dies she dies whatever
gets the whole explanation done to him
or her again and then embarks on a
journey yeah and will forget all of this
by the time they start yeah so and God
is Christopher Walken from click so
maybe it's both 50 first dates and
conversations or God or it's just the
first conversation really don't remake
of there yeah that's my other theory
so yeah mashup I know it's like this
lends itself to get into some really big
sort of like
perverted adversary kind conversations
at the same time I had that my friends
decided to leave it that it city goes
deep yeah I feel like he would love
video just like this yeah yeah I mean I
really like the art style and the colors
and everything and the strain this
almost reminded me of a school of life
video but a little more abstracted and
funnier and Bufo hilarious especially
when your marriage is falling apart your
wife's happening I love that I love that
little character I'll get through it
yeah everything is like traditional
there's really no character exploration
it's not about that it's not it's not
it's about exploring the ideas and stuff
in existence very severe elements but
that I think that goes hand in hand I
want to link it back to conversations
with God in a way because you know they
say the whole purpose of life is to
mature and elect as much experience as
you can well conversations with God that
they really highlight that life is about
experience primarily the simplest of
analogies is like you can't have good
without bad you can't even really know
joy unless you experience and depression
and pain or whatever so having a life
it's like he okay yeah
even though you experienced life it was
a good life there were still since
arcanist
down elements that you left behind and
yeah there was that too but also in a
way by his death she's able to
experience some type of liberation from
at all and a nuanced you know of feeling
bad about feeling that yeah you know
that's very layered yeah and I mean this
I want to see the short film about just
their marriage with the car crash the
previous video but yeah this has a very
sort of all roads lead home philosophy
to it that I've kind of adopted too over
time I like that they sort of pointed
out oh so the Hindus were right well
yeah everybody kind of right in their
own way and if you look at the various
religions in the various metaphysical
because there's also this concept of
reincarnation and the idea that you've
lived past life you've experienced so
much stuff there's like a reserve of
spirit energy that in chance you know
that's that 21 gram mystery that
enchants the human body or whatever
I appreciate it it sounds so cynical
when you talk that's right just such a
twenty one girl [ __ ] or whatever we
might have viewers that really believe
that and you're just insulting that's
right I totally slag that off I was like
that thing is dumb idea that's just when
you poop yourself geez
so 21 grams of please you see a lot of
little you know snippet videos like
these that kind of expound thoughtfully
upon an idea like that especially in the
modern landscape where we do have a lot
of different schools of thought to jump
behind you know we have a lot of
prominent religious figures we have the
rise of you know sort of new new-age you
know beliefs and stuff like that I've
been fascinated by the interplay between
them lately in life and yeah so I like
this encompasses all of them in a way
yeah and it also explores the concept of
you know God is not a giant white dudes
none of your so my guys gonna do a
specific amount of stuff Santa
essentially if you believe that you
believe that going off with this idea
explores is just like a celestial figure
I'm a slow folk phone by saying buff
Santa so I'll give you that and I could
just edit it out but why do you that
yeah yeah the idea of God not being that
kind of figure and also God being an
omnipresent figure so the whole thing
with like time travel like the rules of
time don't exactly work the way we
imagined it and I've heard that's the
way time is in general I like that I
didn't actually try to explore the
concept of what who it God is because
it's not some singular entity or
something like that and I imagine we
possibly couldn't understand in humanoid
form well I think that would take away
from the thoughtful quality it's too big
of a question to be like this is what
God is when having the video still be
effective and not get lost into an
argument I mean yeah of course of course
and I also really love the idea you know
a Kennedy JFK
hmm you heard him got shot in the face
oh yeah if I ever ham like it yeah sorry
to all the fans out to JFK you know he
said that each of us need all of us and
all of us need each of us oh wait was
that him I know he said ask not what you
can do for your country
Nick then I'm but that's not what can
your country do for you as for you can
do for your country
but I believe that was also followed
with that it's kind of hard for me to
dive into but I just kept flashing the
conversations we got with this the idea
of our life it's not that we have this
idle will help listen but the sky and
then the presents everywhere we must
worship it is more about why the Creator
has us is because by us having our
experiences God it it's having I want to
go her experience through us as well so
we are in likewise becoming one with God
so that is also in tune you know it's
like a Christian beliefs say that we
were made in the image of God and I've
had my own kind of interpretation to
what that can be and it's more in tune
with what this video pretty sure if we
do it behind the scenes research of this
the author is just trolling us yeah
there's a hardcore atheist and nothing
yeah you think you live all the
lifetimes you're just gonna become God
it's silly I can't believe you fell for
this well I got a Cerritos get some nice
animation on air soothing and treat more
life of ever like things you're deep yes
parts of life cynicism really what's at
the root of all the universe talking
mainly about ideas explored here but in
terms of just a good short story I get
why it's title short story too because
of the way they chose to just have like
one voiceover for all the voices and air
reading this whole experience to I don't
know if it's difficult for people to
digest is but I found it easily
digestible for something that is rather
well yeah I feel like it's not - not in
a looking down upon you kind of way but
I thought it made it simple enough that
like a kid idiot
yeah and there's something very much to
be said I think for when people can
choose the right words to thoroughly
explain something simply yeah gotcha
yeah it's really hard to do absolutely
well this was beautiful well we just
subscribed and much I got more Kurt's
got Kurt's Sagat verses and bison in a
nutshell I want to check out more of
this channel interesting stuff you guys
can subscribe to the real rejects you
can click that notification really good
note if I would ever got a youtube video
up you can check us out on patreon where
we got TV show reactions stream along
some shows of reaction highlights
included weekly Q&A is he does music
video coverage weekly Pete Don thank you
again for sending this video over to us
we've been talking back and forth a lot
lately and you've been feeling the
inspiration again to fulfill a story a
novel or you see even had a video game
idea recently but he shared with me a
quote and I know a lot of people who
actually watch our channel are creative
types of Spirent writers and I just
wanted to share this quote with everyone
here since we've been getting a little
bit deep he said a video game once told
him which I thought was like the game
talk to you the disc came to me in a
dream sometimes when you're writing a
story your brain gets fixated on a
specific point if you try so hard to
make it perfect then you'll never make
any progress just force yourself to get
something down on paper and tidy it up
later another way to think about it is
this if you keep your pen in the same
spot for too long you'll just get a big
dark puddle of ink so just move your
hand and go with the flow that is very
beautiful mm-hmm also wrong yeah a
hundred percent wrong if you do not
strive for perfection on that first
draft your second draft will suck your
third draft will suck this whole idea
that a writing is rewriting this myth
that has been thrown around not true
pulp fiction one draft I go over every
sentence one at a time and when that
sentence is perfect only then do I move
to the next cent a social network one
draft road one one
yeah Oh Justice League one draft scary
movie 5 OneNote that had rewrites and
rewrite and that's why it was bad
you know they shouldn't rewrite these
rewrites or the key to these movies I
just said they're not I don't mean that
I'm lying you worried yes ending totally
right rewriting the joke see what
happens
no but I Oh improv Pete ah good advice